they crossed the Macedonian border on
foot carrying what little they have left
in backpacks more than 2,000 people
arrive each day the small train station
at give julia is already overflowing in
the early hours of the day everyone here
wants to travel further north as soon as
possible but they need papers to do so
and these are not easy to come by
Mohammed has been waiting for them for a
day now he's an English teacher who fled
Syria before the war began survived a
journey across the sea as well as poor
conditions on the Greek island of coast
now he's stranded we can't pass without
this paper this is a problem but there
are many many many people and from many
nations this is a very big problem and
there is case with all these people the
small town is completely over stretched
the only washing facility available is
by the rails which is exactly where the
refugees sleep there's hardly been any
international support the conservative
town mayor blames neighbor in Greece
Kukui geekiness Greece simply lads all
of the refugees who arrived there
through to us should we macedonians
start working for the army or the police
in order to regulate the border that's
what it can answer the police decide who
will be allowed to board the trains
heading north some people are allowed to
travel on towards Serbia but crossing
the border must be done once again on
foot and in secret on the other side
special buses take the refugees to the
capital Belgrade finally there is relief
many here have had horrifying
experiences okay the top of my two small
children my wife and I floated at sea
for almost an hour yo just sank
fortunately we had life jackets and then
the Turkish Coast Guard arrived and
rescued us Jamaican could tho Jonas
honey but here in Belgrade those without
money or papers have to sleep outside
many parks in the city center are
totally full the memory of the war here
in Serbia is still fresh so almost
everyone here feels sympathetic toward
the refugees but Belgrade is just a
stopover they're eager to reach the
European Union the route to the EU
however is becoming more difficult with
every passing day the Hungarian army is
currently blocking off the border with a
four meter high fence reinforced with
barbed wire this fence is not a big
obstacle on the way to Europe yet since
construction began the number of illegal
border crossings has even gone up but
the Hungarian soldiers behind me are
making it stronger now although even
they themselves don't believe that that
will keep the refugees from coming even
when it's completed the fence is
unlikely to stop the refugees they've
left war and suffering behind and are
determined to overcome this final hurdle